hey how's it going for us my name is
Peter Pan what if what if it's the
question today we'll find the answer so
I played will you press the button a lot
of you brothers really liked it but a
lot of you also said that it was just a
ripoff of this game called what it so I
thought let's give what if a track cuz
what if do that did that work let's
begin what if the Sun shines when you
are happy but it rains when you are sad
yeah cuz the sun shining makes me even
happier easy what if everyone you
attract you get attracted to are
attracted to you alright I can dig that
but you [ __ ] yourself every time you
kiss someone for the first time I'd be a
pretty hard point to get past in a
relationship hey you can just wear a
diaper on the first day and make sure
that the last thing you do on the date
the very last thing is to kiss her and
you don't go into you know or at least
make sure you change your diaper before
you get into stage 2 yeah I'll go for it
haha what your [ __ ] why you're afraid
of [ __ ] yourself Wow wow that's
embarrassing what if your home was
always sparkly clean and all your duties
at home were done automatically oh my
god that would make me so happy but you
must always wear dirt dirty boots
wherever you are you know I take I take
boots very seriously if you have dirty
shoes I will I will silently judge you
so no I will not go with that yes [ __ ]
yeah I'm killing it what if you could
accomplish anything but you had to
sacrifice time sweat and tears to make
it isn't that what we're told
isn't that the truth yeah why not why
not why not give me one good reason why
not
what if you can read people's thoughts
but you fart continuously for as long as
you do it I I don't see farting
continuously as a bad thing I'd wear
those underwear that blocks that smell
from smell of farts and where are those
yes I'll take it [ __ ] you yeah well I
really don't like farting farting is
gross I'm called say no [ __ ] you what if
you were always in good shape but you
have to exercise a few times a week
that's how you get in shape you stupid
these questions make no [ __ ] sense
sometimes they're actually they're just
asking would you like to be in good
shape I'll say yes yeah well I hate
exercises I haven't lost my computer I
mean 84 years what if you enjoyed sex
twice as much all right but your partner
enjoys I think that's the case already
what [ __ ] you Yeah right get out of here
if you don't say yes you don't love your
partner Eric you Eric you you're [ __ ]
eight go home I already don't care for
sex but I don't want to ruin my man's
enjoyable man Amanda you look like a lot
of fun yeah totally what if you can get
a fat ten thousand dollars per month for
25 years but for the next five years you
may never take off your clothes
not even to an extra externa your needs
so you mean I have to piss myself for
five years and [ __ ] my like how was I
even work can I pull down my pants I
know that doesn't mean I take off my
clothes if I put them out right
although [ __ ] naked is very valuable
to me I'm gonna have to say no in this
one it's tough whoo I level up
hey Val what if there was always a new
hundred dollar bill in your pocket
but every time you pick one up a human
dies on the other side of the world a
display of humans getting it oh come on
well the world is about to have a mess
and population drop because I'm gonna
get richer than Bill Gates Bill Gates
have seventy six billion dollars you
would have to reach into your pocket
seven hundred and sixty million times
let's say let's say it takes five
seconds to do that it would take you
forty four thousand days which is 120
years so good luck with that
ha idiot what if you could live forever
but you may never talk to someone again
let's say no that sounds like a sad life
nineteen percent said yes yeah well I
can just talk to Sheree or Evie but if
you never need it to sleep but you died
20 years prematurely uh I don't know if
you bros ever try to stay up for as long
as you can I try to stay up for two days
it gets really boring and it gets really
weird because you don't have time to
reset the day kind of I think mentally
that's really hard to handle so I would
say no a lot of people agree what if you
could take anything without being caught
for it but every time you took something
someone innocent was accused and
convicted [ __ ] yeah what kind of
question is that of course I'll I'll
take it what if you become twice as it
as attracted I don't see how that's
possible but half is smart I don't see
how that's possible I know I would what
if you become a world famous athlete and
earn five million a year but you become
super fine that sounds awesome
the being a super fat world famous
athlete Haley I'll take that what every
badass what if your lifespan is
increased by fifty healthy years okay
but you step on a Lego brick when you
least expect it a couple of times
a couple of times a day for the rest of
your life I'll just wear it I'll just
wear slippers yeah say yeah what 50
years 50 healthy years the hour the pain
of Lego is like the worst and ever to me
and 50 years it's not that long
[ __ ] you what if you never sleep longer
than five hours a night but you could
craft and control your dreams every
night oh [ __ ] yes I would go with yes
ooh level two Wow
well that was what if that was a lot of
fun it's cool
I enjoyed this a lot if you enjoyed us
well please leave a like it helps me out
a lot that's it for now and as always
stay awesome for us this game has one
selling point sorry two selling points
what [ __ ] gets going on the combat is
pretty [ __ ] smooth I gotta say
actually enjoy this